each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
hey good morning ladies and gentlemen
it's an honor and a pleasure for me to
speak to you today about the Internet of
databases and generalizing the RKO
informatics approach I'm here from the
archaeal bio center of the loot which
Maximilian's University in Munich in
Germany and the archaeal bio center is a
research community within the ludwig
maximilian university which has been set
up to do a transdisciplinary work on
archaeology and archaea related sciences
together with biology and with
informatics and out of this interesting
combination we we had over the past five
years a lot of output and I would like
to show you some of the output we have
and to tell you about our thoughts we
have there and what we can do with these
ideas for a more general approach to the
internet of databases as a blueprint for
Annie science system which could be
applied to other scientific domains so
let me tell you a bit about me my name
is cliff somber maiden I'm originally
Dutch I'm living in Germany and I'm a
veterinarian specialist in information
technology so that this means I'm a
veterinarian and era specialization in
informatics that is something which is
unique in Germany that you can do that
and I am the head of the IT of the
veterinarian Faculty of the Ludwig
Maximilian's University now what
as veterinarians stuff to do with
archaeology you might ask now we have at
our faculty the Institute of paleo
Anatomy or in other parts they say
archaeologic and they do the they do the
history of veterinarian science and with
it with this I got connected to an
archaeological logical database they
used and this archaeological data base
we developed over the over the past six
years to what we call the archaeal data
network first let me tell you something
about what we found out what our Co
related scientists actually want because
that is the main problem in in all those
X Sciences as Jim Gray set in the fourth
paradigm those X informatics that
develop the main problem you have is you
have on the one side you have an
implementation and on the other side you
have your ex scientist and they don't
know anything about each other for an ex
scientist and you'd may use tell
something about data mining they think
you are talking about statistics if you
are listening to an ex scientist and
they are telling you something about the
problems they have with in there within
their scientific area you normally stay
there and you can't really directly get
it so it's the first thing is all about
communication with each other so
understand the other side now what we
learned is that akio related sciences
and then that is the first place of
course it's archaeology then it's RQ
zoology archeo botanics but then you
also have the parts of
the guys who count the rings of the wood
and then you have the the teeth and then
you have the part of the isotopes and
then you have the ancient DNA part so
there are a lot of different parts
within the scientific community and one
of the main problems we found is that
they have the archives they use archives
from the 70s and from the 80s they
started with old debased databases and
they put their data in that and once I
put the data in that they put data on
the on the shelf and they don't do
anything else with that so and each
scientist enters the data in the
archives by its own way and they are
arguing about standards and they never
agree on standards yeah so this is this
is one main problem what do they are
what do they want they want on the other
hand they want to have their
publications connected to primary data
that is something with Jim Gray also
said you have to connect the
publication's to the data an example for
this in archaeology is open context org
what do they want they want general help
on informatics they don't understand
informatics so they expect that you will
program whatever they want you reinvent
the world statistics analysis mining
elements is what they want and they want
to manage their large data they have
they have bones they have artifacts they
have the botanics information they have
the biologist information it's huge huge
datasets and these datasets need to be
managed and there is of course the part
of the visualization of what they do I
can give you a little example of what
can be done for visualization of
visualization this is a little project
we did and it is on the visualization of
we churches from the 14th century in the
northern part of Germany at little town
called scheana and what you see here is
that there is the actual ground scale is
is entered into a blender gaming engine
and in this ground scale there was a
basilica build and this Basilica
disappeared and we didn't know why it
disappeared and so we set it up by the
magnetic resonance information we had of
how the church may have looked and what
you see here is that the actual ground
scale you can look under the Basilica so
the Basilica has collapsed is one
interpretation is one possible
interpretation and this is the
information we got by three-dimensional
visualization an information we didn't
had so this is something which you can
do with with easy methods you can come
to you can clean conclusions and this is
what makes archeo informatics
interesting it is transdisciplinary
since 180 years they are used to that
and this is what can be input for the X
informatik development again what is
archeo informatics and as I said the
traditional quantifying of archives the
traditional quantifying archives and
they are they stay against scientific
databases there is difference on that
just having a archive in which you enter
your data is something completely
different from a scientific database the
scientific database needs to be free of
scientific database needs to be modular
you have to be able to connect to the
database and enter the data in any way
you want this will get more important
later on visualization I showed you a
little example on that three-dimensional
projection connection with gifts
beta and this is written down in the
London Carter and just look that up in
the Internet London Carter is the world
heritage to to enter special world
heritage in computer 3d databases for
visualization it's a major project for
mankind very interesting another part of
our Keogh informatics is the ancient DNA
a bioinformatics a bioinformatics is
different from the bioinformatics you
all know because the DNA is more in
stable or is it a lot more it's less in
stable is less stable is less complete
and you need different algorithms to
approach that this is a very very
interesting field on working for
isotopes i mentioned isotopes are
important to find out how a region has
impact has had impact on the development
of the animals there and you can find
out more about the habitat of the
animals and therefore how mankind lived
in that time same with Dendra and Dendra
analytics and what is important in our
care informatics is modeling to modeling
there is a very interesting part it's
written down in a huge text from 9098
from colorado it says quantifying the
present in predicting the past this is a
very interesting approach because we
heard this morning all about predicting
the future but for the archaeologists it
is very important to predict the past
that you have an information by a few
bones a few artifacts and doing your
interpretation on that and you want to
know what happened in 500 years before
this time or 500 years after this time
so
you do the prediction in both ways from
the acura bio center we now start a new
scientific project we do on migration in
the over the Alps over a period of two
thousand years and this is exactly what
this kind of modeling is used I skipped
one part of this that is text analysis
text analysis is also a very very
exciting part of our keo informatics we
did one project on medical texts from
Egypt and we compared to these texts
which were incomplete and we're
hieroglyphs where which we do not
understand where have no translation for
that and we compared these medical texts
with medical texts from the Greek and
try to find if we can do with this
comparison we can find hieroglyphs we
can translate hieroglyphs on this we
were not successful on that but we hope
to do to use the methods in later
projects and get some better results
more positive results what is our
history on our care informatics what did
we do I told you about the dbase
database I found it's a database called
Auto book this database is has been
developed in Basel in Switzerland by
York she blew in there's the 80s and as
I said it was just used to enter the
data and put it on the shelf I did the
first redesign on this database and made
it made it more general usable made it
usable in the network and after that I
contacted the institute of informatics
in God in contact with hunt beta keygen
and Pierre Kruger and from that point on
the development of also booked as now a
standard for entering archives older
archaeological data got on its way
mainly by the thesis of Jana lamprey
she made the mysql database in beta base
intermittently synchronize able just
show you how it works you have the
central database in the Institute you
have local workplaces in the Institute
the database is connected to the
Internet the workers out on the field
collect their data on their notebooks
they have a check out of the database
with the data of their fieldwork and
they enter new bones into the database
and once their home they synchronize it
back to the central database after this
the second idea was when we synchronize
the database is from a notebook to do
the central database for field workers
we also can synchronize databases from
different Institute's to each other so
all these Institute's can now
synchronize their archaeological data to
one central database and they can also
do that with their notebooks on the
field and what you get then is you get a
central database in which you now can do
mining and you can do analysis of the
data and do predictions on finding sites
for example after that we introduced the
system to the bio arc the bio archaean
organization for archaeological research
and we got it to a standard for the
European data entry of archaeological
data the RQ bio center was founded and
we did our implementation of first data
mining tools on the database the thesis
of urea suka nova and svetlana don t
where the first part where we could do
searches on bones for example to predict
of what sex the animal has been from
bones we found it one of the results we
found out there
we did presentation of the database in
Barcelona police and Paris and Aberdeen
publication in hong kong and heidelberg
and then we did a second technical
redesign by daniel current allah and
johan is laura and from that point on we
had really a working system for all the
data now this is how also book looks
what you see here is the entry mask for
the isotope information and the database
is if you see it up front it says
plugins that means it is modular so the
scientists can write their own plugins
for Annalise analysis and it is a
minimal standardization of data entry so
it is flexible in use for all different
parts of the community out of this we
set out of our experience that it is
very very difficult to set up standards
as I said in the beginning we thought
about how can we keep things simple for
those scientists how can we keep things
flexible so what we got up with was the
archaeal data network and this thing is
more than bones you can connect to the
archaea database to the archaea data
network you can connect any kind of
archaeal related diet database that
means the botanical the artifacts
zoological isotopes whatever you think
about and the way you can do that is by
using a findings label you have to split
up the meta information you have you
have to split up the information to a
finding label which has minimal data set
of descriptive data of the finding site
and some additional information about
the owner of the database learnt the
location of the database and now the
important thing is that you add a unique
identifier
to these to these finding label and
store this in a central database this is
the way up in the central database the
unique ID and the way down is an odbc
connection to the underlying archive so
what you get now is when you connect all
these underlying archives by a super
node system you can make any database
web searchable only thing you have to
have to do is you have to lay a layer on
that for a user interface and for
privacy control a simple structure of
the system is that in the field you get
the finding site information and the
central ID is generated this is
synchronized to the other IDs and the
other finding site information within
the central database and the information
is synchronized into the local database
where you have here the finding site
information and here is the rest of the
located data of the project and then you
can do an analysis over the Archaea
database data network over the super
nose over the central database you can
find the local database and you can do
with search and the researcher of his
archive he can he can click if the
information can be searchable by
algorithms it can be searchable
anonymously it can be searchable open or
it can't be searchable that is what what
the researcher can can can choose out
what you have then is you can do
similarity searches on finding sites for
example you can
have you can have a result of a finding
in Argentina and can compare it with a
result of a finding in Belgium for
example and when the algorithm show up
with with a similarity they pop up with
the meta information of the database
which means who is the owner and where
is the database located now this is a
decentralized solution for scientific
databases what we found is that normally
you also only see centralized approaches
that means for a community like
archaeology and archaeal related
sciences there are lots of efforts set
up to set up central archives the
problem with these central archives are
that there are rules on how to enter the
data and the scientists don't want to
have those rules they want to be free
within their databases to develop their
own ideas so the central archives are
politically interesting for those who
want to manage the scientific area like
archaeology but are not interesting for
the scientists themselves so the
individual scientific databases are for
the scientists more interesting and what
they do is they have their database
developed in their own way they are
modular so that they can so that every
user can connect and use tools in their
way they want and they are with that
simple connector connected to the
archaeal data network where the meta
information on stage one is managed so
with this approach you can have an
archaeological database you can have an
aqua botanical database you can have a
database on on teeth and whatever you
think about and you can let them talk to
each other and you can give the
scientists freedom of further
development of its own database and you
can have searched elements through all
these database on privacy level with a
simple user management system so these
are from our point of view this is the
most interesting result of what we did
split up the meta information into into
part simple identification with the
unique central ID and free meta to
information with modular docking of
tools as i said the duo meta information
minimalize the meta one that is the
finding site in our case and at the
central ID you get then the universal
connectivity and search ability through
the databases meta two can be freely
defined it opens the way for further
development of the data and it the
modularity is there for other personal
needs of the scientist so the important
step is separate the common the
connectivity from the data and offer
privacy now generalizing these thoughts
it is not only archeo informatics in
which you can use this idea any data
sheet has any data set has a finding
label
and algorithms can find these finding
labels and or the user who can use as a
connector can use a wizard for that why
these algorithms these algorithms are
important if you want to connect old
databases into new 22 new databases in
all databases nobody ever thought about
connectivity of their data so you use
the algorithm which walks through the
database and says okay here we have what
we are looking for these is the place
where the finding was this is the field
where the pliant we're finding was is
the depth of the finding and you can do
that with any of the data data sets you
want yeah so you can make this
independent of the user by using the
algorithms next step is store the
finding label with a unique idea I ID
into the central database and offer web
searches so what you can do then is you
can do your similarity searches by web
search through a huge set of different
databases use a simple user management
we did that in suites that is three
stages as I said I said block any search
make anonymously search as possible or
make your database public searchable
with all the data in that what is
important to do is that you have to
create a create a privacy protection on
that so that you have the reverse
searches blocked this is something which
needs to be taken care of too because
you can formulate your search and get up
with the information behind it even if
you try to keep it anonymously what can
be done and when my opinion is very
interesting to do is that you can attach
the publication's to the data now you
don't need
the central storage of the publication's
any more like open context does but you
can just link the location of the
publication for your database where it's
linked to you can keep the database in
your place you can upload your database
into a central system if you would like
and you can attach your publications to
your data without bringing them directly
together within the system and there is
something which two years ago I thought
already when I visited the last
microsoft research workshop on e science
is it is not only about attaching your
publications to your data but you can
also think about attaching elearning
elements which come out of the data so
you get a connection of your scientific
research into the into learning of the
students teaching so the only thing
there needs to be done is to hook up to
the internet of databases use the tools
and use the splitting of the meta
information in two stages and here is an
entry an interesting example to do is
for example in environmental databases
if you think about the oil companies in
Canada with the oil sands and they have
to do archaeologic find actual
archaeological on their on their places
where they want to develop the oil sense
they are not pleased to share the data
but when you put the data in certain a
system like I told about then any search
on archaeological data pops up with the
owner of the database and then you can
do direct new negotiations so you can
not only connect
governmental financed research but you
can also connect privacy finance
research and let those people talk
together if you use this user management
system of the internet of databases
people who worked on this yakshi blah
started this in Basel in munich euro
Spader's in henrietta obermeyer in Paris
sisal kalu Isabelle belly in Munich p
occluder and me we have five thesis on
this one on synchronization to one data
mining and two instructors actually
programming of the system is at the
moment one student assistant and two
doctoral researchers on that we have to
thank bior can't of course the ocular
bio center on this and i have to say
thank you very much for your attention
and my special things to microsoft
research on this okay so are there any
questions for the audience sure sorry i
understand there are different kinds of
needs for privacy but I what and why our
privacy for this kind of study it's an
unpublished data is entered into the
database and so the scientists can use
the the database to enter his data and
once he has published he can connect his
publication to that and then he can say
oh I understand yeah yeah I understand
can I just ask one I i understood that
your your initial queries using your
also book system are based on the labels
and the metadata is that it or and once
let's let me tell you what i understood
you you get queries which are to
integrate different
kinds of data which are based on on the
Manta information and from there you can
derive new findings is that it or am I
totally wrong no not totally now the
search goes the first meta-information
stage is only used for the connection of
the database to each other the databases
to each other the analyzes goes through
the different databases inside inside to
the data yeah so it is in the the meta
information layer the first
meta-information layer is only there for
connecting the databases and the
algorithms go straight into the
connected databases hi you mentioned in
the early part of your talk I about what
the scientists want as opposed to what
the ICS people want and I wondered if
that was based on your experience with
your within your own institution or if
you did kind of a broader survey to see
what the general population of
researchers wanted no that's only the
personal experience but we had the
personal experience within the bio arc
community where the first first first
time we came together I was just
wondering what they were discussing
about about discussing their standards
and fighting about the the do's and the
don'ts of their standards that was the
first thing that they agreed on the
minimal standard that was very very
important step forwards then and we
thought also within the German
archaeologic community where there is
the same idea as it is in England and in
Holland and here in the United States of
a central database development of month
central database and the discussion in
there went into the same direction it
was first was a discussion of standards
and with this decentralized approach i
show you here you are free of that you
don't need to discuss any more about
standards so it frees up and it's and it
gives an acceleration to the development
of the data okay all right I think
actually we're out of time when we have
one more speaker up does so I'd like to
thank you again Chris for that lovely
talk